we are throwing them into the deep end
of the pool and we want to see what
happens that and that's where the
excitement comes from our show is
totally real my name is Ted Allen I'm
the host of the show chopped on the Food
Network I had never been on camera
before I was on queer I and somehow I
know that TV cameras freak a lot of
people out it's just never bothered me
when I'm doing chopped I'm just being me
we have a rotating array of nine judges
who have become just fast friends we're
all so close we all were so passionate
about food all we have to do is show up
on time and talk about cooking
techniques and ingredients that we love
and ingredients that we don't love and
how things might be put together best
and the proof is on the plate you know
so if it if it's good it's good and if
it's not see you the casting actually is
quite a complicated process we're
looking for chefs who are interesting
and colorful and that have great skills
and we want people from all over the
country every possible walk of life
different ages want to have plenty of
women and plenty of men and it's harder
than it might seem
as difficult as it is to do the show to
compete on the show it's it's it never
ceases to amaze me how many people want
to do it TV is a little more complicated
to make than it is to watch and TV that
involves food is particularly
complicated because obviously everything
has to be safe and fresh it's about a
12-hour day to make a 46 minutes show
someone has to decide what what
ingredients are going into the baskets
every basket has a riddle in it that is
known to the people who make the basket
I doubt that in a 20 minute cooking
round many of the chef's figure out that
riddle they just start chopping but if
we give you say silken tofu and lavash
bread and tomatillos maybe we're looking
for a riff on grilled cheese and tomato
soup good luck figuring that out I get
picked up at 6:30 in the morning which
is much too early so we get there we
have a little breakfast we I get into
wardrobe I read my script and make sure
I'm happy with it
and change a few things here and there
for a regular episode I'm up there by
about 8 the first drive is 20 minutes
the second and third rounds are each 30
minutes but there are a whole lot of
shots that have to be shot before those
rounds can begin there are so many
different angles that we have to shoot
we've got something like 1012 cameras
going some of the most dramatic moments
in a competition like chopped happen
unexpectedly for example some let's say
somebody drops a steak on the floor and
they decide to go ahead and serve it
anyway we need to make sure that we have
a shot of that steak hitting the floor
and that's why we need the coverage from
so many cameras because we don't reenact
things we don't staged things and we
have we have to capture everything the
rounds are scrupulously strictly timed
and people have exactly 20 or 30 minutes
to get done if they're not done too bad
they're actually laws about shooting
game shows that have cash prizes there
are strict rules about the way these
shows are run and you have to live by
those rules first of all the chef's do
not know what's in the mystery baskets
it's scrupulously we that is kept from
them they open the basket they typically
have about two minutes before they have
to start cooking with the ingredients
that are in each mystery basket we're
looking for variety we're looking for we
want to represent different ethnic
cuisines we want to represent American
favorites
I think the audience likes it best when
the basket ingredients are horrifying
we've had pickled pig lips on we were
lucky enough to be shooting in New York
City which has markets that sell
absolutely everything there is at least
one shop in Chinatown that sells nothing
but mushrooms that New York is such a
great food capital that we can get
anything we need once in a while we'll
give people a basket that's that looks
like it's a slam dunk you know a New
York strip steak and potato and some
cheddar cheese and it seems like the
easier the basket the worse the dishes
it seems like the chef's almost need to
be challenged with you know something
really scary like a whole chicken in a
can
we have to base our decisions on what is
on the plate
sometimes the winner of the of a chopped
competition is not our favorite person
you can't base the decision on who is
popular who is charming who is cute
you can't the rules sort of save us from
that if somebody omits a mystery basket
ingredient that's a huge mistake but
somebody else maybe could burn - the
ingredients or undercook one of the
ingredients and burn another and we find
ourselves asking all the time what is
the greater crime cooking can definitely
be dangerous there are flames there are
sharp edges there's a small amount of
counter space
we have surprisingly few injuries and
what we've had have always been minor
I've been doing this for 10 years and
I'm not I never get bored with it the
only problem I have with the hosting
shop is that my feet hurt
whenever you start a show there's no
guarantee of success and so they
typically will order a modest number of
episodes I think our first order was 13
episodes we had no way of knowing what
our longevity was going to be or what or
whether people would embrace it I think
chopped succeeds in part because of the
excitement and the tension were forcing
them to cook with ingredients that they
didn't get to choose but I also think
that all of us who cook have had those
nights when the kids are screaming for
something and you haven't had a chance
to go to the market and you open up the
fridge and you have to make do with what
you have I love working a Food Network
for a lot of reasons I think probably my
favorite aspect is getting the
relationships that I've built with all
these really really talented chefs and I
mean I have alex guarnaschelli's phone
number on like if i have a problem with
a recipe i can text her I also think
that our judges are super knowledgeable
very entertaining funny we've had a
little bit of foment in our judges ranks
and our most recent acquisition Martha
Stewart I think is a very very exciting
one I've been a fan of hers for 25 years
and now I get to work with her it's
amazing well I'm super grateful super
proud I love our team it's a well-oiled
machine of really great people and
letting almost entirely by women which i
think is exciting in television and
we're we're happy to keep making them as
long as you want to watch them